let me ask you something
your your um beef with quick
which i know you've talked about to the
death
right um anybody who wants to kind of
dive into that
there's plenty of content out there of
you talking about what happened
um do you think that you
and and quick's beef resulted in
because every time some something like
that happens
people choose sides like do you think it
it it resulted in you losing any
opportunities or
like you losing out on anything because
people might have
like chosen up or perceived you a
certain way during that
during that period um i've never looked
at it like that because i've always
looked at myself as the underground kid
100 i've never looked at myself as
the kid that the [ __ ] would
want to come to
period and i always accepted that in my
mind
embraced it i i never felt like
oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] getting this
and i ain't getting it i've never felt
that never because
at the end of the day i can make some
money
i love to write and do hip hop
my bills is paid boom my kids
ain't starving and ain't struggling and
don't have
[ __ ] holy shoes and looking for a
handout
i'm fine i've had opportunities right
that came along that fit me i mean i had
the boys in the hood soundtrack
i had minister sadie in a row uh thicker
than water with mac 10 came along
wow you know i forgot about that one i i
i i
was nominated for a grammy with with
kendrick for the song
should have won that grammy yeah
macklemore yeah yeah
yeah but you get you but you get it you
know but
i've always embraced my position in
hip-hop
and i'm cool well when you when you it
with anything right
right you look at other people and you
try to judge your own happiness based on
what other people are doing
that's where you get [ __ ] up man yeah
that's how [ __ ] become
depressed and they become unsure of
themselves you become [ __ ] up if you
do that if i start going damn
how come i ain't like snoop or how come
snoops wrapped the same [ __ ] i was
rapping or how come i'm not like
kendrick or right quick or i've never
done that because i never felt like that
when you heard uh man i'm not gonna lie
some of those quick records were
were vicious on some rapping [ __ ] like
when he's the one line that stuck out to
me when i
was the e-f e-i-h-t now should i
continue you left out the g because the
g8 in you
you heard that what was yo were you like
man [ __ ] this fool were you like
it's hip-hop were you like yo that was a
nice bar you have to come with good
lines in hip-hop did you at least like
respect his like
like i don't think when you beefing with
cats
that you look at him as far as uh
whatever you know but i was never
like oh i'm feeling just blow the [ __ ]
up because the [ __ ] i looked at
it as hip-hop banter
could you at least acknowledge like okay
quick i got something for you or like
yeah that line was kind of
that that was a cool line i've always
felt like i had perspective
in a hip-hop perspective i've always
felt that's just like a [ __ ]
saying that
i don't think i'm number one i'm number
two or number two nobody should you
always give yourself the credit of
whatever so
in a hip-hop world because
i never took [ __ ] on record personally
so yeah good line when [ __ ] would be
like oh that was wonky room i said from
hip-hop perspective yeah it was a good
line
i mean just like [ __ ] would say
oh what you said was all killer or
whatever whatever
right and i say it's all in the aspect
of trying to be clever
when you trying to diss a [ __ ]
right you can't diss a [ __ ] on a
weak [ __ ] i tell [ __ ] today
i've been dissed by some of the best
[ __ ] so if you're gonna diss me you at
least got to come with something right
correct
don't come with no weak [ __ ] because
then what's the point right
that's facts man yeah now we're just
people just make instagram videos about
each other
i mean [ __ ] [ __ ] make an
instagram video or do some dumb [ __ ] or
whatever but
like i said we came from the class of
of writing was everything man
your pen game man give a [ __ ] about the
beat man you gotta write some [ __ ] cuz
let's face it a lot of [ __ ] had some
whackass [ __ ] tracks back in
the days too
but their [ __ ] penmanship was just
great like
you'd be like god damn man how did he
come up with that [ __ ]
so we prided ourselves on writing so
you had to come up with clever [ __ ]